[Musica]
Scusate
l'emozione 4
anni quante cose si possono fare in 4
anni sicuramente ognuno di noi avrà una
visione diversa
ognuno di noi saprà cosa è riuscita a
fare quanti progetti ha elaborato
pensato magari anche realizzato 4 anni
del resto sono tanti
anche adesso vorrei portarvi nella mia
vita indietro di 4
anni La mia vita è ripartita da
qui era il Maggio
2019 quando mi fu diagnosticato un
cancro al
seno in quel preciso istante la mia vita
crollò il mio mondo si è fermato il
tempo si
fermò avevo tantissime domande nella mia
mente
avevo 40 anni tanti progetti da
realizzare come un po' tutti noi Voleva
aprire uno studio di Personal Train
voleva avere dei figli con mio marito
però quel Maggio 2019 cambiò la mia
vita Ho vissuto le 24 ore successive a
quella
diagnosi come le più lunghe della mia
vita però erano solo 24
Ore Io sono sempre stata una
sportiva Il solo pensiero di potermi
ammalare mi rendeva vulnerabile non
poteva succedere che tutto questo stesse
accadendo a me avevo mille domande
appunto mi chiedevo perché Perché
proprio a me ho
sempre seguito uno stile di vita
sano Però quel Maggio
fu mi sognò
profondamente il tempo si sa passa per
tutti passa per tutti noi
inesorabilmente non sappiamo quanto ne
abbiamo a
disposizione non sappiamo se sarà mai
sufficiente a realizzare tutto ciò che
vorremmo
però il tempo non deve essere un nostro
nemico bensì un alleato
speciale il
tempo essere gestito nel migliore dei
modi Perché solo noi possiamo essere
artefici del nostro
tempo mi viene in mente un dialogo che
probabilmente in tanti di voi conoscono
tra Frodo e
Gandalf nella serie nella saga del
Signore degli
[Musica]
Anelli Avrei tanto desiderato che tutto
ciò non fosse accaduto ai miei giorni
esclamò
Frodo anch'io annoi Gandalf come
d'altronde tutti coloro che vivono
questi
avvenimenti ma non tocca a noi scegliere
tutto ciò che possiamo decidere è come
disporre del tempo che ciè dato dovremo
lottare con accanimento
avremmo dovuto farlo anche senza questo
terribile evento
al nemico Manca ancora una cosa che gli
possa dare la forza e la scienza
necessaria a demolire ogni Resistenza
distruggere le ultime difese e far
piombare tutte le terre in una seconda
oscurità gli manca un anello
l'unico Noi
combattiamo combattiamo per ciò che
vogliamo combattiamo per ciò in cui
crediamo combattiamo anche contro i
nostri
nemici togliendogli le armi necessarie
per farlo
sopravvivere questa continua lotta
servirà a noi per
vivere e così accadde dopo quelle 24 ore
quelle infinite 24
ore accadde proprio questo ricominciai a
vivere la mia vita iniziai a parlare un
po' anche con me stessa iniziai a dirmi
mirata adesso Alza la testa e guarda
oltre prendi tutti quei pensieri che hai
nella testa analizzali uno per uno e
vedrai che un passo alla volta tutto
andrà per il
meglio così Un passo alla volta divenne
Il mio mantra era la mia
forza e tutto ripartì anche se con
qualche
difficoltà la settimana dopo mi
operarono e ricominciai a Vivere il mio
tempo come per
magia dopo 10 giorni dall'operazione
tornai subito in
palestra con le mie cicatrici in bella
vista Sinceramente non mi importava
molto delle
cicatrici perché quei momenti che
passavo a fare sport a fare attività mi
donava benessere mi donava benessere
psicofisico mi donava
felicità mi donava Libertà voglia di
ricominciare e anche di ritornare a
gareggiare
ripresi ad amare il mio tempo ripresi ad
amare il tempo che mi era stato
Donato anche se appunto tutto questo non
era mai così semplice da
fare ma ritornai a
vivere ma nel settembre
2021 mi fu diagnosticato un cancro alle
ossa alla quarta vertebra
lombare loro la chiamarono recidiva ma
sinceramente per me era un altro stop
l'ennesimo stop dovevo ricominciare
tutto da
capo Tutto questo
mi mi mandava il cervello un po' su
tutte le
furie ho avuto dei
crolli la mia vertebra si era
ridotta Veramente era diventata
piccolissima purtroppo avevo tantissimi
dolori non mi reggevo molto in piedi
e così passai il mio primo mese a letto
guardando solo ed esclusivamente il
soffitto mi svegliava al mattino e
vedevo tutto bianco
e andavo e richiudeva gli occhi nello
stesso nella stessa medesima posizione
ero sempre
lì mi sono un po' rimboccata le maniche
mi feci dare un busto lo Chiamai
stritolo stritolo il bustino faceva
anche
rima Chiamai stritolo perché appunto
come lui Nessuno al mondo mi ha mai
stretto così forte e lì
avevo una posizione quasi eretta mi sono
ho ripreso a sedermi come una persona
normale ricominciai a camminare anche
per solo per qualche ora e ricominciai
anche a lavorare facendo la personal
trainer era anche un po'
complicato però quelle poche ore che
passavo il mio tempo lì a dare anche del
Benessere alle altre persone ad
aiutarle mi dava sollievo mi dava
serenità aspettai quattro mesi infiniti
prima dell'operazione
dopo l'operazione già il giorno dopo mi
misi in piedi non volevo stare
oltre entrai lunedì in ospedale martedì
operata mercoledì ero in piedi giovedì
volevo essere assolutamente fuori
dall'ospedale perché dovevo Ricominciare
a vivere riprendere la mia vita in mano
e fare quello che veramente volevo
fare iniziarono ovviamente le terapie
che non sono mai
leggere che continuo a fare tutt'ora ma
in maniera un po' più
soft e
così Un passo alla volta iniziai a
sconfiggere il maledetto
Sì perché il per me era davvero
maledetto lo lo chiamavo così giusto
anche per sdrammatizzare quella
situazione per 15 mesi fui costretta a
fermarmi da qualsiasi attività fisica
non potevo fare nulla 15 mesi davvero
lunghi
sono passati 2 anni da quella seconda
diagnosi di
cancro quella sono io subito dopo
l'operazione il sorriso non mi è mai
mancato non mi mancherà mai perché è la
mia
forza e quelle sono le viti che mi hanno
messo all'interno del del busto per
essere in posizione retta senza nessun
un altro
ausilio ma adesso Vorrei ritornare
indietro
ritornare alla domanda di inizio speech
Non ti addormentare eh Ti ho
visto quanto sono 4
anni pochi o
tanti è difficilissimo quantificare il
tempo possono essere lunghi 24 ore
possono essere corte perché abbiamo
tantissime cose da fare possono essere
lunghi 4 anni ma anche
brevi infatti la risposta esatta è
dipende perché dipende da ciò che
facciamo tutti i giorni
Dipende da come sfruttiamo questo
tempo Ricordiamoci sempre che più
viviamo il nostro tempo nel migliore dei
modi così come vogliamo
senza pensare a quello che vogliono gli
altri ma così come vogliamo noi il tempo
ci restituirà
vita il benessere psicofisico è la cosa
più importante che dovremmo
avere dal tempo che
scorre io ho trovato
benessere nello sport e nelle mie sfide
sportive ne trovo una al giorno sempre
diversa ma quello è un problema mentale
dovrei andare da da uno
bravo ricominciata a
correre ho ricominciato ad allenarmi ad
arrampicarmi a portare cose strane sulla
sulla spalla a girare le ruote che non
sono quelle della fortuna Ma va bene e
tante altre sfide ho nella mia mente
da fare nel prossimo
anno il politico britannico William pen
che visse nel Settecento disse il tempo
è ciò che più desideriamo Ma che ahimè
peggio
usiamo Ecco adesso vorrei proporvi un
giochino prendete il vostro
smartphone
Io già l'ho fatto non lo prendo lo
rimetto in tasca tanto ho già segnato
tutto Aprite il vostro
calendario e mettete una nota fra 4 anni
il 30 settembre
2027 Porca miseria è
lontano nella nota scrivete come ho
usato il mio tempo negli ultimi quattro
anni Ripeto così AV come usato il mio
tempo negli ultimi 4 anni sembra di
essere a scuola Allora avete scritto
bene
bene quello che vorrei trasmettervi
è decidete fin d'ora Cosa volete
rispondervi
perché il tempo che ciè stato Donato è
solo nostro e solo noi possiamo decidere
cosa farne e nessuno niente e nessuno
dovrà mai metterci il bastone tra le
ruote Grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
n